this morning on the dish a master of
Middle Eastern cuisine whose
Philadelphia restaurant has become a
must visit venue for food lovers
chef Michael Solomonov was born in
Israel after coming to the US he began
cooking Italian food before turning to
the cuisine of his homeland
in 2008 he opened Zahav with a menu of
modern Israeli cooking the reaction was
immediate aha became a destination
restaurant and earned solomonov last
year's James Beard Award for outstanding
chef and the 2016 awards for both
cookbook of the year and best
international cookbook and chef Michael
Solomonov congratulations thank you
welcome to the dish when I give you a
table of the Year dish because I don't
know where to start this looks so good I
think that you have to just roll up your
sleeves and dig in you know you could
start with hummus and pita all the
little salad team or a cos a little
Yemenite soup or if you're like me you
just go don't stack of donuts yeah a
bite of this donut nobody this I don't
have exactly Yahoo I read did not really
even like tomatoes until you were 18 so
how did you get so far I don't know what
happened like I I was terrified of food
I still am a little bit scared of
mayonnaise but I was my grandmother who
is from Bulgaria originally but but
Israeli would come and visit like once
every other year in Pittsburgh where I
grew up and she would make bori cos
which are this amazing Sephardic Ottoman
they sort of tell the story of the
Sephardic Jews and they end up being
this breakfast food the staple in Israel
that's on every corner and that was the
one thing that I sort of loved so when I
attempted college and dropped out I
ended up back in Israel with like no
skills right because you being an art
major with like three semesters I know
Hebrew doesn't get you super for not
wanting qualifications there right so I
would like go up and down the street
begging people for a job I got a job in
a bakery and they made the bori goes
there
that's the magic negative all started
open Zahav in 2008 which was not exactly
a great year to open a rest
not certainly not an Israeli restaurant
in Philly I mean that was the year that
we won the World Series which is awesome
if you have a television and don't serve
Israeli food right the economy was
already in the worst part of the
recession yeah it was not not a great
year and we almost closed and luckily we
did we got a couple good reviews and
stuck to our guns and there we are and
then you decide to open federal donuts
knowing nothing about donuts not so much
in the doughnut right exactly not
qualified at all to open it so why not
my business partner Steve and I met
Tommy Bobby and Felicia our other
partners at federal donuts and we all
filled in and figure this out and kind
of like winging it and then on day one
we sold out of donuts and Fried Chicken
we do donuts Fried Chicken and coffee so
we cover it all and we like on day one
or day two we sold out of everything and
we're like no or I guess we're onto
something you've described as Raley food
as the last frontier what do you mean
well I mean I think that when we when we
opened everybody was my generation
everyone is like very into Spain and
before that it was sort of Italy in
Branson and I think that I think that
even Israeli chefs in Israel would would
go abroad and then they would come back
and like serve food that they found
other places but like what we have in
Israel is amazing it covers a hundred
different cultures a hundred different
astronomy's and it's such a new country
with such old tradition you have this
melting pot and why I go anywhere else
and you've got seven different countries
that are represented at this plate and
then you know so on and so forth so
cooking and dining perspective a
super-fun chef as you sign this dish of
custom if you could share this bounty
with anyone past or present who would it
be I think you talk for being rid of an
amazing statement Statesman and I'm sure
a just fight her and it was like their
honor anyway probably would have like
just smoked cigarettes and I Nina
chef Michael Solomonov thank you thank
you thanks so much for having me and for
more on chef Sal Amano than the dish
head to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com